[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning high
school football returned last night in
fairhope alabama
that's near mobile as you can see on the
screen many fans they are not wearing
masks and that's in violation of school
rules
the principal says he wanted people to
cover up but quote
we can't make anybody do something it's
just one example of the problems that
schools and colleges all over this
country are facing
as the coronavirus cases continue to go
up now some teachers unions say they
will not be forced to work in those
conditions
that they say and that they feel are
unsafe our national correspondent david
becknow is in miami
with more on this story david the
question there is how far the union's
willing to go now good morning to you
good morning to you look here in florida
they're suing in fact today they're
going to deliver their
closing argument they're fighting the
mandate that the school system is saying
you have to have in-person classes
other teachers unions are saying listen
if we're not going to fight you in court
we're gonna fight you in the court
of public opinion and we're gonna
threaten to strike
five six seven eight we won't go
until it's safe new york city teachers
protested in brooklyn thursday
demanding that the city implement what
they say are essential safety measures
in the midwest teachers in detroit say
they're prepared to strike
if the city does not provide adequate
testing before classrooms reopen
and out west one arizona school district
delayed in-person learning
after teachers there staged a sick out
some experts are urging local officials
to just
err on the side of caution it can't be
schools as usual this fall
we can only go back when community
spread is under control and when
aggressive risk reduction strategies are
in place within the four walls of the
school
you know risk reduction appears to be a
problem at colleges across the country
schools in at least 17 states have
reported positive cases
on campus parties like this at north
carolina state university
forced that school to put all classes
online
at purdue university in indiana 36
students
were suspended for holding a party in
violation of the university's health
rules
at penn state university a party outside
a freshman dormitory was broken up by
campus police
and its syracuse hundreds of freshman
students many without masks
were seen gathered together on the quad
now the university says it may have to
shut down campus
before classes even start it's
infuriating to
see people my age thinking that they're
just kind of
invincible patrick pinfield is a senior
at syracuse
he's also a coronavirus survivor he
caught the virus during a semester
abroad and says he dealt with lingering
symptoms for four months
he's urging other students to remember
what's at stake here
everyone wants the college experience
everyone wants to party
it's syracuse university and i want to
have a college experience
too i want to have a graduation i want
to be able to go to class
and it's just not going to happen if
people don't follow the guidelines
there's going to be consequences and
there's going to be a lot of angry
people
you know dr debra burks who's a part of
the white house coronavirus task force
is now advising colleges to invest in
surge testing what does that mean
she's recommending that colleges do five
to ten thousand tests every day that's a
lot
but it gives you an idea of the type of
scale that's needed
to handle things and try and get back to
some type of normalcy
tony yeah it's amazing that we're
talking about scaling testing all these
months after the outbreak but here we
are
david bagnoff david thank you very much